one of the things we have learned the
hard way over the last 25 years of not
only teaching millions of families how
to get out of debt and how to start
building wealth and really build wealth
and get into the world of investing in
that kind of stuff
learned it ourselves Sharon I learned it
ourselves is used is not bad we come now
from a generation current generation
most of the things you buy today are
throwaway items if your DVR or your DVD
player doesn't work you pitch it and you
buy another one almost all the time
they're 50 bucks but when we use to buy
a VCR you know some of you are old
enough to know what that is it's these
huge tape decks things and there were
like $3,500 for the VCR recorder if that
thing broke there was actually an
appliance repair place or a TV repair
place and you took it down there and
they would repair it there were repair
shops in your community that would work
on small appliances by and large they
don't exist anymore there's a few people
that still do that but it used to be
there would be a TV repair shop that
it's often sold new TVs as well but they
would you could take your television
there and have it repaired can you think
of where there's one in your
neighborhood now your LCD flat screen
goes bad you know what you do most
people pitch them we don't work on stuff
anymore in our culture we just replace
it when it breaks now and because a lot
of things in our you know even something
as simple as a toaster people used to
would repair a toaster or a blender in a
generation ago that's what we did no one
does anymore I'm not saying it's bad but
here's what's happened in the throwaway
replace culture you've started applying
that to washers and dryers and they can
be repaired and there are still people
that will repair them matter of fact we
have a very nice washer and dryer at the
Ramsey household it got a three hundred
dollar repair bill the other day
gentleman came and put a new little
doily
thing on it or a little push button
thing on it or whatever it was it went
bad for miss Sharon Ramsey took care of
you repair those they're repairable and
used ones by large you know can be
repaired for 25 50 bucks whatever in a
lot less than whatever it costs to buy a
new one but this idea that somehow you
have to buy a brand new washer and dryer
because old ones break well new ones
break - oh by the way the same applies
to cars when you buy a used car
they break oh when you buy a new when
they break - but you don't toss them you
repair them and so when something breaks
whether it's a washer and dryer or the
fear of something breaks I don't want to
buy $100 used one instead of a $300 new
one on a single mom I live in an
apartment my last caller no you buy the
hundred dollar used one or the $50 used
one and if it breaks you get a repairman
and repair it if it the repair is going
to be too much you throw it away because
it's $50 or $75 at a garage sale or
Craigslist but if you do $300 when
you're a broke person on a washer that
you could have bought for 25 50 or 75 on
Craigslist that might break see that
that causes you to stay broke did you
spend several hundred dollars more same
with a car repair lady they called
earlier in the hour move down in car but
the new car that bought off a repo lot
had at $300 worth of repairs and she's
in panic mode the car is a bad car we've
made a bad decision we're in if you
spent three hundred bucks on it you
probably paid more that you probably got
you probably saved more than 300 bucks
off the value of the car when you bought
it on a repo a lot to start with
probably got a bargain on it calm down
and repair the item it's okay to fix
things it's okay to buy a used item and
fix it a couple of times and put up with
a hassle until you're not broke anymore
not when you're not broke and you want a
new one just because the old one broke
and you want to just toss it or trade it
or whatever it's okay you got the money
then but you'll never have the money as
long as you keep buying brand new things
that break you in the moment meaning you
brand new things you can't afford
because the used ones might break I
can't drive a used car they're not safe
you're heard people say that that's the
dumbest thing I ever heard
a used car is not safe give me a break
it might break down let me just tell you
they all break down brand new cars break
down and a friend of mine bought a
hundred and fifty thousand dollar car
the other day and three weeks after he
bought it the tire was flat
it breaks down he ran over nail breaks
till it happens you know that's just
stuff happy things break they're going
to break it doesn't mean you can't buy a
nice enough thing that it's not going to
break and so this idea that I always
have to buy new when I'm broke we'll
keep you broke buy used fix it repair it
until you're not broke any more and then
you don't have to buy you scrap anymore
Drive like no one else so later you can
drive like no one else wash your clothes
like no one else so later you can wash
your clothes like no one else I mean
this thing that Sharron bought it I
think you can fly it if it had wings
it's ridiculous
it's a ridiculous washer and dryer but
she can afford it because we've lived
like no one else we paid a price for a
long time for decades we put up with
trashy bad stuff the first washer and
dryer we bought we got married 32 years
ago we paid $25 for the pair now that's
a long time ago but seriously and the
stupid thing lasted like the both of
them the washer and the dryer lasted
like three years that's a pretty good
number now you can't do that today it's
probably going to cost you more than
that but still that's the idea it's okay
to buy used put up with a little hassle
you're not going to
doing this for a period of time so you
never have to do it again
you